[Music]
I'm not a brilliant businessman I just
have enough common sense to see that
there's something that needs to happen
and so we jumped on it we provide
security solutions to the cannabis
industry there's more dispensaries in
Denver than there is Starbucks because
the federally insured banks are
prohibited from making marijuana money
we've got clients that you know are
making two three hundred thousand
dollars a month in cash and they don't
know what to do with it they have no
security training they're not security
minded looking for someone following
them and they might put it in a shoe box
or a pillowcase in their closet so they
use us to transport it in our armored
vehicles and we have safe storage in our
facility because the banks won't take it
I've been in the industry for about 15
years
my background is law enforcement in the
United States Marine Corps it was a very
unusual dynamic moving from arresting
those who use in smoked marijuana to now
defending the people that we deal with
they might meet you we're trained to
look for any choke points pinch points
ambush sites or anything that's going to
Fox our trucks in most of the banks they
want a degree of separation they don't
want a dispensary owner walking in with
$200,000 in cash that smells like
marijuana we actually have a service
where we wash we don't launder it we
wash the money we actually have a
machine that removes the marijuana
molecules so it does not smell like
marijuana and then we deliver it to the
banks there's now 23 green states our
intention is to be in every one of them
the potential for growth in the spaces
is unlimited for us
you